hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play mushy
picks there's no time to waste on me on
the wrong way we have to go down this
long and dark hallway where I'm sure
nothing bad is gonna happen in
everything's gonna be hunky-dory yay hi
oh good oh look nothing bad happened oh
great you know I was worried for a
second there I so worried for his take
in there that something bad was gonna
happen and I was this gonna be say what
no what was that I hear you are you the
big giant electric Pig electro pig where
are you where are you
I hear you stomping around oh my god
boys invisible how's that even fair he's
invisible oh he must be like the water
monsters trapped between the two worlds
Oh
okay what happened
did I get him what happened
back on iron oh wow
I hear you I see you you're like
flipping in and out my light is
flickering oh oh oh just let me pull
this thing let me get that now
yeah oh you so Oh
what happened did I get him did I kill
him did I stop him into another
dimension what the hell happened I
thought he was gonna come charging
through and break down these things but
that might have been a little too big
boss battle esque was strange well I
mean it wasn't much of a threat I think
I think I got it
can they do it I I guess I did it good
job everybody thanks for your undying
support now what the hell do I do
oh okay there's a door over here okay I
miss that I'm terribly stupid hello
somebody here okay other than the
electro Pig doesn't seem to be much
going on okay open door over here okay
all right close it art oh oh I heard
static electricity
I assume the electro Pig was back little
piggy zap zap mandus processing company
electrogravitics oppression south tower
what does that even mean I want any ER
science mumbo-jumbo blowing up my brain
mandus descending amongst the spirits
the Aztecs believed they could avert the
apocalypse through sacrifice history
tells us they failed their tragedy was
simply that they could not spill enough
blood in time really was that it did the
House Dax try to build this machine is
this where Manus got the crazy idea
they've been alluding to the Aztecs for
a while now so I'm just under the
assumption
oh my and to save you only to spare you
I would have given my soul to spare you
this world and it slow uh-huh
this world in its low May okay
now's n5e - I wonder if those mean
anything okay apparently not
I'm not gonna remember those numbers
like what if like that
stop like reminiscing on how terrible
apparent you are in let's get to work
here unless I put it right to my
darlings all of my wrongs will be
righted all of my sins washed clean okay
I don't know how thorough you're gonna
be watching here but uh you kind of got
the blood of a thousand thousand souls
on your hands there's a damn teddy bear
again memories they surface like bloated
bodies rising to the scum of the Thames
I looked at them covered in the blood of
their dead mother little piglets
squalling in their swaddling in my heart
it once was filled with a great love and
a consuming hate I could never have
imagined at that point did my soul split
creating him was this the egg of my soul
the moment the great clock began to tick
it's the only path to redemption to join
us together again to make myself whole
to close the Great Circle and take that
madman into my heart once more and
forgive him and myself as well I love
you my darlings and I am sorry I am
sorry for all I have
I simply loved you all too much this
world yeah if that's what they call love
I'll stick with hate why was that
noteworthy
I searched for instructions for advice
for helping my goals but in return the
system mocks me simpleton it says you
must find your own answers now well you
kind of have been holding my hand
throughout this entire game I don't mind
going out on my own thank you very much
it's biggie
that's biggie come on little piggy come
out little piggy go home little piggy no
no little piggy come out to play
little piggy gonna play with me put
aside your misguided crusade and let me
save them how about [ __ ] you mate
mandus but I have seen the future your
20th century and let me tell you this a
far greater slaughter awaits you bear I
seek to save the world by brat now
history under my blade and gasps uh-huh
yeah about that well I mean I don't
doubt you but uh okay what the [ __ ] was
that
what the hell
what happened oh no laughs again Oh Lou
Bega Don oh hi how about your father
how about that who I read up okay all
righty
good thing he's not very fast goddamn
close it door oh that's the first time
I've ever been able to close a door in a
monster I miss that from the first dam
knee-jerk god damn no not again
oh you stop that oh is this where I was
before I think so
oh and that's about time you started
[ __ ] with me Matt damn album sitting
there pleasantly waiting for the moment
when you would start throwing me around
cuz I like that thought of stuff I like
to be thrown around Oh call me dirty
threaten my hair oh no no no no no yes
no I wanna be scared game scare me so
good scare me so good so good ahh
game over there we go ok I don't know
why I needed to climb up that I probably
didn't immediately what is this whoa
what did I just do
I start spinning what does that mean
okay what does that mean what did I do
there's a bunch of these woosh harmonic
resonators do all right
there's all four woosh I haven't even
looked inside here but there seems to be
some sort of son of you now breach at I
will destroy you Oh
screwed you time to end this madness is
it is it really is it uh feels it really
time is it really okay maybe I gotta go
dag down again
who's gonna come after me the giant pig
that I sent into another dimension did I
or did I
I don't think that there were things so
I gotta go in aha
what the hell is that is that an orb oh
my god is that an orbital oh no way oh
no way
oh god help me I lost the drive made the
soul of the world were
what happened Enoch headwind Oswald and
I who's Oswald Oswald is a new one
who I
okay I'm oh man things are getting
interesting now hello oh my to save the
world I am your friend not a very good
friend I will admit that what is this
what are in those things I can barely
see them oh my god what are those hello
oh hi hello dude how you doing friend
are you what I think you are say what do
i do what do i do what do i do how do i
rip the sky part with my bare hands wait
maybe I just there's a walkway here what
do I do
alrighty then hello
I thought I saw something up and I no
more evil than you we saw the same thing
to save humanity
ridding them of their painful stupid
pointless lives I don't think that's
what I wanted
stop think about what you were doing for
your children Mendez do not speak of my
children not stuff I did not kill your
children matters you
your sons will trow lungs full of mother
shrapnel on the banks of the song you
wanted to save them from the horrid
economy that is the vision we shall
we are to avert this coming nightmare
you
one another same our souls are entangled
we deserve to make them free
they don't seem very free friend they
seem to be then trapped in the nightmare
of my mind
okay what is that is that a piggy piggy
looks like a piggy baby sitting on
throne or burning alive I'm not sure one
or the other hello kids how you doing
okay can I get off this conveyor belt of
madness a morning of some of those
scream screams were the sounds that
people submitted for this game
might've been who knows these things
whoa-ohh have stood knee-deep in mud and
bone and fool my lungs will mustard gas
I assume two brothers for I have known
with holy wars and populated with the
autumnal fallout I have dug trenches for
the refugees I have murdered dissidents
were the ground never thaws and starved
the masses into pain a child shadow
burned into the brickwork a house of
skulls in the jungle the business the
innocent man desert rump and leg and
gassed and starved and beaten and
murdered had enslave this is your coming
century
they paid some you all and they barely
less out into your face
eat your
Oh
this is it this is a machine that I saw
in the beginning at least I think it is
please for your children right
oh wow
am I going on a rollercoaster ride some
really really bad one whoa all right
here we go
oh right
well there you have it I'm not sure what
exactly that machine was ever gonna do
other than harvest people but for what
purpose
I'm still left with a lot of questions I
mean I felt like it was trying to
resolve its justification for what it
was doing but without realizing its
purpose to the god I had created down at
the end when we were cold as the stone
we had huge his body drunk when the
lights were nearly all extinguished we
heard in the silent fifties the man
takes singing to another then as the
last lights were gone and we laid
together in deep they drifted away and
all the Sun such a silence I have never
learned
and as the dust settled on my open eyes
and we lay together embraced forever
I heard miles above us the sounds of the
city turning over in its sleep
the church bell when ya
and in that moment
the new century was born
you
okay so that was the conclusion of the
game that was um that was I have a lot
of things to say about the game first
off I gotta say that it was a lot more
story driven than amnesia when and and
it was I think it was made to be as
different as possible while still
connecting amnesia more now it's hard to
formulate my thoughts about this wall um
while it's so close to the conclusion um
first off I have to say that I always
emphasize that a horror game should tell
a great story and that was a really
incredible story that it tells but at
the same time I felt like the story was
trying to be horrific more than the game
itself was because the story at its base
if you if you were reading a book about
this would be a very very gruesome and
horrible tale and and really really
involved and thought of Oken but at the
same time in the game it felt like it
traded some of the gameplay for the
story itself like as I was going through
the game I was kind of being walked
through it you know I was never always
in control of what was going on because
you know it felt like I was kind of on
Rails at a time because as soon as I'd
keep moving forward I never got lost you
know I never really got lost because
there was nowhere else to go I mean
there was that one segment where I go
down two hallways to get what I need to
but they just looped back to the same
place you know um I kind of feel like I
lost the sense that I was in this world
and on my own and I never felt like I
was really in danger at all because it
wasn't like an amnesia one where these
monsters came out and these monsters
that were just horrifying and awful and
just absolutely disgusting but they were
also hunting you I never felt like I was
being hunted even at that last part with
the big electric big it never seemed
like it was actually a threat to me
because it never seemed to like come
after me it just was kind of lumbering
very slowly long plodding and you know
there was that whole lost mechanic I
didn't need to hide once in that entire
game I didn't need to hide at all so I
feel like a lot of the gameplay was
sacrificed and a lot
what I really liked about the first
amnesia was lost which was just the
feeling of helplessness throughout the
entire game and and I never felt this
like overwhelming fear it was scary at
times and it was very dark at times and
that was good but it wasn't like it was
when I played the first amnesia where I
literally had to stop playing and go lay
down it was it was never to that point I
mean there was one time where I took a
break and was like oh my god I catch my
breath but in the first ami I couldn't
play that for more than you know 20
minutes at a time and that's back when I
was doing 10-minute parts I couldn't I I
literally couldn't do it it was just
absolutely horrifying and and I feel
like this one didn't have the same spark
and I wish it did I wish I could say
that it did but at the end of the day I
feel slightly disappointed and I played
dear Esther and I know the Chinese room
made this one and I know that frictional
games is working on a separate game and
that's not amnesia related and so that's
why the Chinese rim was working on this
one and frictional game finished it up
once they delivered the final product
and and but at the same time I don't
know even in the darkness of the machine
you know I felt like they were trying to
add a lot more to the setting of the
game and stuff like that I felt like
they were adding a lot more involvement
to the environments because some people
complain that in amnesia one it was to
say me because this text same textures
were always used the same dungeon the
same walls you know there wasn't a lot
to work with but you know it just kind
of felt like I was getting lost in the
clutter because it didn't even matter as
I was going through it and being walked
around and it looked great did and it
felt great in the atmosphere was good
but I don't know it's just it wasn't
quite what I was expecting to be it's
still a great game I would still
recommend anyone play because that story
was really really cool and if you take
your time through the game you're gonna
find that there's a lot of cool stuff to
see and you don't want to miss out on it
but at the same time if you're expecting
the same thing as amnesia one it's not
there it's it's not the same it just
isn't that's just the way it is so take
it out for what it is I still recommend
the game I still think it's a good game
it's just not what I expected it to be
and it's probably not what
you're expecting it to be so I'll leave
it at that I still liked it I enjoyed
this playthrough hope you did too thanks
for sticking with me through the whole
thing so thank you all so much for
watching click the end it takes you four
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video okay
alright Wow
sorry for dropping in like this but I
had a few more thoughts that I wanted to
say about amnesia a machine for pigs now
I'm thinking back to a lot of the RPG
horror games that I play they don't have
a lot of graphics to deal with so they
gotta emphasize more on the story and
now this game that we just played has a
great story especially if you go back
and think about what happened to get
from A to B it's a it's an incredible
adventure and it's really cool to see
and it it's not entirely long but it
stays as long as it needs to be it
doesn't drag on at all and even if it is
on Rails like it kind of was it's still
told a good story now if you take
amnesia a machine for pigs a name and
just throw amnesia out of there and just
call it a machine for pigs suddenly it
doesn't need to be compared to the first
one and as a standalone game this was
very different from amnesia in the first
place and that's not a bad thing but it
only is a bad thing well it's not a bad
thing by itself it is only a bad thing
when you put amnesia in the name because
if you do that and people were expecting
from this sequel and reason why a lot of
people are disappointed is because it is
the sequel to amnesia that's what it was
touted by doesn't matter if we was made
by the Chinese room and you can see a
lot of elements from dear Esther in
terms of storytelling similar from aid
be you know they took it from their
previous experiences and they took the
the ideas of amnesia and tried to merge
it together and they created what they
thought was right and that's okay if it
wasn't amnesia you know this is amnesia
this is what it was supposed to be and
people were expecting to be scared even
more than the first one because that's
what they wanted that's what the people
wanted the people wanted a great story
but at the same time they wanted to be
scared out of their mind
they wanted to have their minds just
blown at the horrors they wanted to pee
their pants crap their pants and
everything about this and that's why you
know it's kind of disappointing to come
out of this game with that in mind but
you know I applaud the efforts that they
tried to do here I just don't think it
was right to put it as another as the
sequel to amnesia in fact a lot of the
efforts about it seems like it was just
tangentially related I mean they threw
in the notes where they talked about the
original monsters and what they did with
the experimentation but it seemed more
of a side thing because they never
really explained what the Machine did
what did it do I don't know no one ever
knows because they were just pulling in
people from the streets feeding into the
machine I'm assuming to get vit de to do
something but what it was I do not know
they were trying to save the world from
being destroyed by killing everyone in
the world see it doesn't make any sense
to me and that's why I feel like it
shouldn't have been at the amnesia
sequel I think it should have been its
own standalone game and then people
would have accepted it for more of what
it was I mean they may have compared it
to the original amnesia but at least
then it wouldn't have been directly
correlated and set up this expectation
that it just kind of didn't meet it was
like it was good it was great it was
scary it was creepy but it wasn't the
horrifying pants-wetting experience that
we were all asking for okay now that is
that that is what I'm gonna say I'm all
done that's it so take that for what you
will so seriously seriously thank you
guys for sticking with me through these
longer Let's Plays I want to do more
longer Let's Plays on gaming and stuff
like this because I feel like you know
there are better experience with people
to watch because they get this whole
long invested series that is really cool
I mean I used to do just a whole bunch
of indie horror games but at the same
time those were always one video things
I want to I want to I want to have
something with a story I do enjoy a
great story and that's why some of those
RPG makers are so fun to play in some
some so fun to watch and I enjoy making
them for you and I enjoy making these
videos and giving my opinion on the game
itself and just out what I think it's
all
so hopefully we'll look forward to more
I know people have been have a lot of
games that they want me to play and I've
got a big list of games that I'm going
to be playing in the near future so
sincerely thank you guys so much for
watching I really do appreciate you
sticking with me for so long you know
this is a reason why I do this to to
entertain you with these videos and
given my commentary and what it is
because in the end of the day I'm kind
of a game reviewer maybe a little bit
just a little bit so anyway I'm gonna
stop blabbering because it's been going
on way too long so thank you all so much
for watching click the node if that
don't do any of that
just sincerely thank you guys for
watching and get ready for the next
video in the next series and the next
adventure real soon so thanks again and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye
bye bye
a
to be or not to [ __ ] off